so i saw this video of a cop forcingly
removing a mass subway commuter for
asking him to put on a map at first i
was confused because there are signs all
over the subway stations and subway cars
asking people to wear a map but then it
occurred to me maybe the nypd don't know
how to read so i skated to my local mass
scan in chinatown to pick up some mass
for them and myself because unemployment
benefits ended and the government deems
the economy more important than human
lives doesn't mean that we're not still
in a pandemic i went to dunkin donuts to
get some pig bait i thought my look was
giving but not everyone seemed to agree
finally i hopped the turnstile like all
new yorkers do previously when i tried
to give them masks as it was mandated on
their job as cases were skyrocketing
they refused them so this time i got
creative and attached mass to a fishing
pole with donuts as bait and finally it
was time for me to go fishing okay they
say we don't have enough of a social
welfare net here in the united states
let me just point out that this human
being spent their entire day doing this
and putting it on tik tok and somehow is
still gonna have enough to eat for
dinner so i would suggest that we need
to change our incentive structure maybe
you should get a jab